[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
good morning thank you so much and thank
you all for joining today's briefing
with operation warp speed
to discuss distribution of the kovid 19
vaccines briefing today is dr monsev
slowly
chief science advisor for operation warp
speed and u.s army general gus purna
the chief operating officer and
co-leader of operation warp speed
dr slowly and general perna will make
opening statements after which we will
open the line for on-topic
questions all statements provided or
answers to questions during today's
briefing
are on the record we kindly ask you keep
your questions related to the topic of
the briefing
when asking a question please state your
name and media outlet and please keep
your questions concise so we may answer
as many as possible in the time we have
any additional follow-up may be sent to
media hhs.gov
please stand by as we prepare for the
live stream
dr slowly you may go ahead
is a number of important questions
that would effectively relate to
important
progression or development such as for
instance
can we use at least in some of the
populations immunized
somewhat lower though into those regimen
which may be an alternative that is much
more powerful
to induce a high immune response than a
one dose vaccine for instance
where of course also as we already
announced uh
started the first adolescent clinical
trial
uh from the age of 12 to
18 and finally also
have started the practical aspects
operational aspects of gearing towards
identification of correlated
immune protection in your occurrence of
protection sorry which would be very
important to
identify to help
bridge this vaccine as well as other
vaccines
now that potentially the running of
placebo control deficits rise may become
more challenging
particularly in the u.s and in countries
where vaccines will be
approved and in use the jnj johnson
vaccine program continues to progress
very well
we told you on monday that the trial
recruitment had closed
uh we are now working with the company
diligently to
optimize data cleaning events
assessment uh and um and also uh
cnc aspects with the hope that we would
be able to
uh file for the ua uh late in january
or more likely early in february and
have vaccine doses
available and approved for use in the
u.s population
as of the month of february the
astrazeneca phase 3 program
in the u.s is also progressing very well
more than 70
27 000 subjects recruited in this 30 000
subject trials so
we can see that the closure of the trial
in terms of recruitment
uh is going to be uh soon and
clearly this program will also be
potentially impacted by
further analysis of the ongoing uk and
brazil
trials when that happens of course we
will
all learn about that together the two
protein
vaccine programs continue to progress
nova vaccine
advanced discussions with the fda we're
gearing up to start the phase three
trial any time
and the sanofi program as per the
announcement is
we are designing together with the
company the phase 2b
plans that can enable further
development of this vaccine
in particular for instance potentially
the use of immune correlance of
protection
those are identified through the modern
and and potentially
the uh the pfizer vaccine program these
are the
the news directly on the vaccine
portfolio
clearly you are also aware of the
uk variants and now the south african
variants
and their potential presence in the u.s
i think
while there is data suggesting but not
demonstrating
that these variants may be more
infectious
than the uh currently uh
you know
most important vaccine strain uh sorry a
very strain
in the population there is no evidence
to support that
uh their pathogenesis
or impact on because that may be
any different uh there are also uh
discussions and other scientific
conversations
actually around the uh study of the
potential allergic reactions associated
with uh the black team uh
we're thinking about potential physical
trials to to uh
to assess that on the therapeutic
portfolio side of things the uh
most important move of course is the uh
announcement of the u.s government
and now we have uh finalized and
announced
uh an agreement to acquire between 60
000 and 100
000 roses of the cd24s
program medicine communion has developed
i
reminded that this
medicine has shown impressive
efficacy in an interim analysis as
as part of a first
interval analysis of their phase 3
program i want to stop there and pass on
to
my partner and co-leader general thank
you
dr slavik thanks great rundown as always
and uh
just uh good afternoon to everybody as
we uh get settled in
uh right before the holidays there's
been a big week of delivery of vaccines
uh over uh 7 800
uh deliveries uh by the end of tomorrow
uh as we are are delivering the 7.9
million
doses of vaccine that were allocated for
this week
around the country really a tremendous
feat
uh yesterday morning we allocated uh for
next week's ordering
4.67 million 2.67 of pfizer and 2
million
of moderna jurisdictions are working
through the planning now
the microplaning and then as early as
tomorrow morning
uh throughout the day they can begin
ordering for deliveries that will happen
next week so today uh we've allocated
15.5 million doses of vaccine
and we are on track to allocate
another four and a half to five million
next week
which will bring us to 20 million doses
of vaccine
allocated to america before the end of
the year
uh we'll finish those deliveries uh in
the first week of january
uh four five six um in january to make
sure that
all those doses are available to the
american people
we are learning uh some lessons as we go
that i want to share with you
uh a tremendous herculean task
uh work being done uh by pfizer
moderna mckesson ups and fedex
we went with them because they are the
best
and they know how to do this but at the
volume
and the scale of what we're doing every
day
we are learning some things to help us
just continue to get better every day
so as we figure out the pace for picking
and packing vaccines
and putting them in boxes making sure we
do the right quality control
we've had to adjust our timelines just
just a
mathematical problem to make sure we
start on
at the right time and we finish in order
to make the deliveries
we are working with uh the states in
collaboration to make sure that we have
a continuous contact with everybody
who's receiving the vaccine
so that we can make sure that they know
when the package is arriving or if the
package will be late
we're confirming and always getting
better at development of addresses
to ensure that we know the right places
to go to and there's no delay there
and we continue to grow in our efforts
with the long-term
care facilities as we
enter and help them administer shots
uh in volume uh really a terrific effort
there
collaboration with all the states uh and
as we
uh operationalize that that that task
we get better every day and when i say
we i mean cvs and walgreens
who are really doing terrific work
at the end of the day we have had a
handful
of packages that we tried to deliver
that
uh we're not destined for the right
place but we captured them before
um they were uh dropped off and we
rerouted them to the right place
uh and we had a couple uh of uh not miss
shipments but shipments that didn't go
out
uh on the right day we wanted them to go
out for delivery on tuesday
and delivery on wednesday uh and so we
had to work through
uh our after actions report and get that
corrected
uh really tremendous work uh being done
uh
uh at the tactical level um at the
worker level to to make sure they
understand how to do this
again reminder uh over the last two
weeks we've done
over 10 000
shipments to different locations and
really pretty impressive
and so i just passed to you that we're
learning we're getting better
and every day we're getting stronger our
goal is is we come out of the holidays
we're in a steady drumbeat of continuous
vaccine delivery
we want it to be even smoother every
single day
so good good job so far continue to do
better
as we go we're working
now uh we're talking to the jurisdiction
states on the delivery of the second
dose remember uh we've talked about
we're delivering the first dose of the
two dose regiment
and we've been holding on to the second
dose
we do we did that to make sure that the
supply chain
was sufficient to ensure the second dose
was there
well pfizer vaccine started being
distributed
last week and it'll be time for that
vaccine to start going out to the
american people next week
so we've established an elaborate
communication strategy
at all levels to make sure everybody's
tracking this
we work through um uh different levels
of
teaching uh and instructions on how to
make sure we're doing that
and everybody's informed we know how to
do this
america knows how to do this we've done
second doses before
what we're just trying to reinforce is
that the second dose availability
and time to order it for it to be
distributed down
and prepare for uh second shots the week
of for
january uh so we're ahead of that we're
ahead of the curve
uh and it's about communications open
transparent
uh and collaborative to ensure our
success
so i will close uh this year uh the
the year here uh this week's uh uh
briefing on behalf of
dr salawi and i um we normally say
thanks to all the men and women serving
around the world uh
and their families in defense of our
great country
but both of us would just like to say
thank you
thank you thank you to the men and women
who are on the front lines
right in our hospitals emergency rooms
uh he uh uh i uh excuse me
icu's right the doctors the nurses the
people that support them
24 7 uh really truly on the front lines
uh and our hats are off to everything
they do so with that said
um i just want to say uh happy new years
and merry christmas to everybody
uh and uh on behalf of dr slowly and i
so please questions
great thank you very much all right so
that will begin the question and answer
session
if you do have a question you may dial
star one unmute your phone and record
your name and media outlet
clearly it is required to introduce you
if you would like to withdraw the
question you can dial star two
again it's star one and our first
question here will come from
dan vergano with buzzfeed news dan
your line is now open thank you dan
pagano buzzfeed news
um and happy holidays guys uh dr slowly
invited us to ask him about his views on
unblinding the clinical trials an
earlier session i was wondering
does he does he have a view on whether
uh the modern one should be unblinded in
the way they want or more like the
pfizer vaccine or perhaps in a double
blinding fashion that was advocated at
the verb pack meeting
thanks very much thank you for the
question
well uh my personal view is i think
it's very important that we unblind the
trial at once
and offer the placebo group to receive
vaccines regardless
of their risk level uh for a number of
reasons
i think the most important is that these
men and women volunteers
have been instrumental and critical in
helping us develop these vaccines
and they should be rewarded for it
recorded for it rather than
in a way punished for it by
for instance uh being delayed and
receiving the vaccine
as as as a number of time
has been proposed and secondly
it is the the pfizer which i think is is
intellectually a very elegant and
appropriate one
practically is a very difficult one
because in real life
every state of our 50 states is going to
make a different decision
in terms of priorities within the groups
group one or group two parkinson's
and therefore the the companies that and
the
clinical trial sites are going to be
scrambling to appropriately
provide the vaccine to the right uh
sub-population
within uh each state and then the third
reason
which i think is also very important is
that there are vaccine doses that have
been
planned for this their stability
lifespan
is limited by not immunizing the food
population
at this stage we are going to lose the
opportunity of using these vaccine doses
which are different from the vaccine
that are being
distributed and different simply
different batches and
they are not counted as part of the eu
those that are part of the clinical
trial material and we would lose the
opportunity to immunize
quite the size of the number of
individuals without competing
with uh the rest of the population
and all of this if we do it should
incent
more people to participate in the
upcoming
clinical trial or ongoing clinical
device because
it will remain good probably for the
next two to three months
but participating in a clinical trial
it's a faster way to
access vaccine than
than otherwise that's my my opinion we
see with the fda and what the companies
ultimately decide thank you for the
question
next question thank you
our next question here will come from
tom howell with washington time
tom your line is now open hey uh thanks
for doing the call can you give us an
update on the long-term care facility
partnership with cvs and walgreens
how many sites have they reached so far
and what kind of
impact do you expect this effort to have
on mortality rates
um since nursing homes have been hit so
hard by the pandemic thank you
so i i can answer the first part uh i'm
not qualified to answer the second part
so
we've been in 12 states uh 238
facilities
uh have been uh executing this week
uh and really uh tremendous
tremendous effort uh in in getting
everybody
done uh i mean walgreens and cvs are
being received by cheering crowds
uh and they're operationalizing their
efforts to make sure
everybody uh gets the shots etc uh it
really
uh uh important to note it is a big
uh effort as those 70 000 total
uh i see us multiplying capability and
capacity
uh every day uh as we as we go
and more vaccine becomes available for
for example
we already know that uh next week that
we are going to
uh be in close to 13 additional states
uh with another thousand facilities uh
that that will start to enter
and every week we're just building on
that uh as we go
it's remember it's based on the
governor's state's plans
right uh as they're working through both
um
frontline uh healthcare workers and then
the long-term healthcare facilities so
it's a it's a mix in the strategies
and we're enabling their plans
as uh as regard the second question part
of the question
you know the vaccines whether the or the
fisa vaccine
achieve their maximum level of efficacy
within 14 days of the immunization and
then
with the second dose probably the
immunity
is for the real forest and prolonged in
terms of
its persistence uh of course we did not
have an
outcome on prevention of death but we
did have an outcome
trial of prevention of severe disease
100
for both vaccines and i think it's
reasonable to assume that will translate
to the prevention of them
and therefore within two weeks from
starting to immunize
subjects that are living in long-term
care facilities we should start to see a
decrease
in the overall mortality in the country
even that the last time i looked
about 50 unfortunately of total death
toll
associated with the epidemic came from
those populations
the priority should be to maximize the
number of individuals
in the long-term care facilities if we
want to
decrease the death toll associated with
the pandemic
clearly this these are decisions that
are ultimately made
at the state level there are enough
vaccine those
to immunize uh the more or less three
million
uh individuals that are living in such
facilities in this state
thank you next question please
thank you our next question here will
come from rachel rubine with politico
your line is now open
i was wondering if you guys could give
an
update on the allergic reactions in the
fiber vaccine
one if you have a total of how many
reactions there's
been and then how many states and also
um if there's any um more information
about what the reaction is to and um
also just real quick on the syringes
since there can be extra doses are you
guys sending
extra syringes in the ancillary kit
thank you
thank you maybe i'll take the first part
and then the uh the answer
is maybe tomorrow address in terms so i
i have not had an update today yesterday
there were six cases uh on a denominator
that we know
is lagging by two to three days
uh today's denominator is about a
million subjects
it may very well be substantially more
than that
uh that frequency uh as it stood
yesterday
uh is uh superior to
what one would expect with other
vaccines
we would have expected uh in the range
of
maybe
i'm unaware of any reports associated at
this stage
with the model of acting in regard of
what's happening there are discussions
with the companies in the nih to
consider running clinical trials
in highly atopic very allergic
subjects that surgical instance i have
to carry an epipen with them all the
time or
have very significant non-atopic
reductions
to immunize them with this vaccine
and potentially other vaccine and
prepare
the the rate of reactions but also
critically
be able to harvest you know serum and
blood cells etc
to analyze their immune status prior and
pointlessly after
such reactions may happen if they happen
i think that's really the the way to try
to understand
exactly the mechanism what is it that's
provoking these interactions
is it a true anaphylactic shock
i think uh we're not clear that's the
case is it
um past cell degranulation which is one
of the ways by which we can have
uh this kind of reaction that's
associated with the
fact that we have particles that are
injected uh is it something else uh
is it is it antibodies should be for the
internet like all of
egg as it's known uh in which case uh
this may be different from one
scene to the other because they're using
different formats
these are only important scientific
questions
uh that could be addressed into this
clinical trial
uh it's being uh discussed as a priority
because clearly time
is important but at the same time we
continue to monitor
this reaction now six cases out of
three hundred thousand or six or a
million subjects immunized i think
while important to understand still does
not change
the safety profile of this vaccine
particularly now that we know
that those reactions can happen and
therefore uh immunization
sites are equipped with the right
medicines
and interventions to help uh subjects if
uh and when they have such reactions
i'll pass on to
uh didn't happen in regards of the
anti-very facts and the uh
i assume it's these six uh those per
provided question
so uh with respect to the ancillary uh
kits in support of the vaccine in this
uh in your question the sixth dose if
available
uh we put extra uh capability in the
kits
right uh so that we would have an
overage just a little naturally
uh as well as combining most of the
administration going on right now is in
major
hospitals etc where they have access
to syringes and needles accordingly
we have adjusted uh our contract and
our construction of the kits to be
um to even provide even more
uh capability as we go forward uh if
they choose to
um if six doses still continues to be
available
down the road so feel very comfortable
with the uh the availability of syringes
and needles
uh and our ability to put these kits
together and continue the simultaneous
distribution
of the kits with the vaccine
thank you
thank you our next question here will
come from angelica libido
angelica your line is now open hello
this is angelica libido from bloomberg
news
um question for you general purna what
do you make of the fact that about
1 million of 9 million available doses
have been administered so far
and are there any actions the federal
government can take if you feel like
the vaccination is moving too slowly so
i'll i'll uh i'll start and i think
maybe
dr salawi might be able to help me a
little bit as we go
first of all i think it's a very good uh
uh pace as we serve we know the states
have a very
uh all of them have a very good plan
it's a you know it's a deliberate plan
uh it's about uh access to the vaccine
when it arrives and then
execution and we feel very strongly that
they
uh really really have set up and they're
immunizing
uh quite a quite a bit of people
the as dr sally mentioned earlier
there's a lag in the information
as it's collected from all the really
thousands of administration sites um and
we know that there's probably at least
a 72 to 96 hour lag in the
information uptake um with that said
we are in collaboration we talk every
single day
with jurisdictions to make sure that
we're facilitating their plans
and we're best to add capability and
capacity to help them
uh either through maybe pharmacies uh
or extended use of distribution sites
so i do believe that'll progress uh here
quickly
as as the two things come together but
uh dr slowly anything to add to that
i think you covered you covered it very
well uh
you know i think it's it's important
that the states are able to
uh increase the cadence of immunization
uh but it's also important that they do
it at a place
where they are in control and that no
mistakes are made
or no accidents are happening that's
super important particularly
uh at this point and we are of course
here to
hear their tasks
and specific demands now we can
operator next question please please
thank you very much
our next question here will come from
peter lopez
your line is now open peter
hi it's pete loftis from the wall street
journal
in the past you've talked about um i
think getting to
100 immunizations by the end of february
or by march
and that in the second quarter i think
anyone who gets who wants one could get
vaccinated
but i'm wondering how you get there is
it with
increasing supplies of these first two
vaccines
or does it depend upon the introduction
of a third or even a fourth
vaccine
uh i think that so the
100 million immunizations can be
achieved
with the 200 million doses of vaccine
for modern hypervisor that both
companies are committed
to deliver between now and
the end of the month of march
immunization is completed after two
doses
and there are approaches where we may be
able to
accelerate uh the delivery of the doses
for the middle of the month
of march the full immunization
may actually depend to be achieved by
by by the month of march depending on
whether there are delays
in the delivery of the last losses from
our fighter could depend on the opponent
of the nonsense vaccine as i said in my
uh introduction that's a one dog vaccine
we have completed recruitment in the
study
there are cases occurring very
significant number of cases
it's very likely that there will be uh
anonymous maybe either an income
analysis or a final analysis on efficacy
we are very hopeful based on the effects
of served after one
the messenger rna vaccine that high
efficacy will also be
achieved with this vaccine but of course
we need to wait for they can see that
in effect and that's that may very well
allow for an emergency utilization fight
in
the end of the month of january or early
february and we're working
hard with the company to make sure that
vaccine closes that are actually
produced and that will be
physically there and in the month of
february
can actually be released from a
regulatory standpoint
because of the facilities in which they
are produced or
feel finished and that's what was
ongoing with the idea as we speak
and jnj if that was to be achieved that
can be quite a significant
contribution to the vaccination of the
population in the month of
february and then more in the month of
march
so i think the likelihood that 100
million people be
immunized by the end the
first quarter of 2021 uh
are very high and then the second
hundred million options that we now
executed
with modern and pfizer uh should allow
in itself to immunize another 100
million individuals
during the second quarter of the year
2021
in addition uh j j janssen's
vaccine can significantly further
increase that number
and you know we'll see what the
astrozeneca trial
brings that's very likely to
and allow for an emergency use
authorization probably
end of february or early march
and then probably more in april we'll
have an e-way of the mobile class
vaccine
and maybe in may uh an emergency
usualization of the the son of evacs
this is how
we plan there's a significant redundancy
as we start the second quarter or to
achieve the
the next 200 million vaccines
and as i said last time about 80 million
of the population is below the age of 80
18 sorry and
for those indications at this stage
only the 16 to 18 years of age is pulled
for
the father vaccine and tries our own
going with
moderna and and actually also with the
youngsters vaccine
and those may actually go
somewhat later into the summer because
their approval may
be slightly later
thank you operator we have time for two
more questions
great thank you very much our next
question here will come from erica
edwards with nbc news
erica your line is now open hi thank you
so much it's eric edwards with nbc news
i'm hoping you can clarify something
um and i apologize if dr slough we
addressed it his audio is a little bit
garbled i don't know if there's any way
to fix that but
um if i understood correctly the
original projection was to vaccinate
20 million people by the end of this
year um it seems like
20 million vaccines will be delivered
which is different from actual
shots and arms is there now uh you know
a change in the projection for how many
people will
indeed be given that first dose by the
you know
within the next group yourself thank you
sorry the uh the commitment that we can
make
is to make vaccine doses available
and uh really to give at least the first
and i think that commitment is met
exactly how
fast the um of immunizations of shots in
arm is happening is is
slower than we thought it would be and
as i said earlier we're here to
to help the states uh
to accelerate that appropriately
so that that objective is not met in
terms is unlikely to be
20 million people with a shortened arm
you know maybe you'll be surprised
yeah we'll have them allocated uh before
the end of the month
uh as dr salawi said and then they'll
the last
uh you know five million will be
delivered the first week in january
and then you know uptake from there so
really i think uh strong message
in that we're getting the vaccines out
as fast as they are available
thank you
thank you and our next question here
will come from candice troy and candace
your line is now
open hi uh dr slower can you clarify
what is being explored for the modern
dosage
is the idea that people would only be
given one dose possibly
and how quickly will you know how soon
will you know if that's possible and is
that being explored for pfizer as well
well i mean as i expressed a few more of
the times i think even a wonderful
vaccine is totally inappropriate
at this stage why because the data we
have generated
is with two doses we know that the
second node increases the strength of
the immune response
about 10 times in terms of antibody
response
we know that memory is installed much
much
stronger in a stronger way after a
second those
system is designed to learn the first
time it feeds an antigen
and then to really you know burst
uh when it sees it again that's exactly
what we do when we give two choices
of the year every two years every five
years that's how the immune system is
designed to work
and and therefore pursuing a one note
strategy
with something where the house life is
short is is
i think something that
should be tested experimentally not in
third because we see protection for 14
days
or seven days in the uh or
that's right and by the way that's
exactly the question we were asking with
the unsensed vaccine
and in particular i think i said that
before the young sense vaccine
its biology started after the immune
response continued to go
even after 90 days after immunization in
contrast to almost all
protein and messenger rna vaccines
now what we are exploring is to take
advantage of that
second dose very significant boost of
the response
and decrease the immunization and you
can achieve
again twice all the quantity of vaccine
polymer vaccine reacts
by giving two doses of 50 micrograms for
instance
and it takes two trials of the modern
trial since
uh the data obtained have suggested that
the 50 microgram those and the hundred
micrograms
are substantially equivalent
particularly
very old and therefore that is an avenue
that is being explored
and discussed with the company and
on that i'd like to uh in the name of
all the people in the operation uh thank
uh all uh all the people into the
operation
they have participated in thousands or
tens of thousands of people
uh in in the manufacturing sites in the
laboratories
in the various agencies in the private
companies madonna fighter
j and j also seneca norway
sanofi and gsk but also all the
manufacturing
companies and and critically
the now uh well over a hundred thousand
subjects that have volunteered into the
clinical trials that are
going into the u.s merry christmas happy
new year to everybody
and we look forward to significant
progress being made between
our next next opportunity to believe
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
thank you for joining the call today
please direct any unanswered questions
to media hhs.gov
and have a happy holidays thank you very
much
[Music]
[Music]
you